[Música]
nuevas medidas en parís para contener el
avance del cob y de 19 la capital y 3
departamentos aledaños fueron declarados
en alerta máxima por lo que se
prohibieron las reuniones familiares
cerraran los bares y aumentaran las
restricciones en restaurantes el aforo
de las universidades bajará 50 por
ciento tenemos informe
el presidente de eeuu donald trump
rompió la cuarentena para saludar a sus
seguidores en una caravana aunque se
mantuvo adentro de un automóvil y con
tapabocas su salida del hospital walter
reed generó críticas por exponerse el
mismo y a otros sus médicos dicen que
podría ser dado de alta hoy mismo y
volver a la casa blanca
tenemos el análisis
los buenos días de combates por el
territorio separatista de nagorno
karabaj a armenia y azerbaiyán se acusan
mutuamente de atacar áreas civiles
cientos de personas han muerto y la
capital
stepánek el reporto de ataques con
artillería pesada reporteros de france
24 están en la región autoproclamada
independiente
comienza la semana y también las
noticias de france de 24 y es que
comenzó la entrega de los premios nobel
hoy fue anunciado el primero que
corresponde a medicina
asamblea la asamblea del nobel en el
karolinska institutet decidió otorgar el
premio nobel 2020 en fisiología o
medicina conjuntamente a harvey y alter
harvey boulter markel hold on my all
hope tony charles en bryce por el
descubrimiento del virus de la hepatitis
c hay tests y varios su descubrimiento
permitió que ahora existan análisis de
sangre altamente sensibles para el virus
que prácticamente ha eliminado la
hepatitis por transfusión en muchas
partes del mundo y ha mejorado así
considerablemente la salud global así
fue la explicación del instituto
cambiamos de tema en francia dieron a
conocerse nuevas restricciones en parís
para contener el avance de la segunda
ola de contagios del hobbit 19 cierran
bares en la capital y su periferia
también a partir de mañana y se
restringe el número de personas en
universidades y en restaurantes el jefe
de la policía de parís de viaja la lema
anunció las medidas bucle del show with
durita la ciudad estará junto al estado
apoyar a estas medidas no efectismo
estaremos atentos para que exista una
transparencia para que en 15 días
podamos salir de esta situación y
hacernos sostenible en su nutrición soft
y donde sets y cohesión este es el
elemento fundamental para mí adaptarnos
en el largo plazo y sólo será posible
con estas medidas poco bonus de adif
para conocer más detalles vamos a parís
con nuestra periodista natalia ruiz buen
día para usted de natalia y cuáles son
las nuevas restricciones
y muy buenos días pues como ya ustedes
venía adelantando lo la principal es
este cierre de bares a partir de este
martes además de esto la prohibición de
todo tipo de consumo y de venta de
alcohol en la vía pública y también de
reuniones de más de 10 personas en la
vía pública a esto se suma la
prohibición de todo tipo de ferias de
congresos de circos por espacio de 15
días cierre de gimnasios y también de
piscinas aunque en éstas todavía podrán
ingresar los menores de edad porque
viene un periodo de vacaciones escolares
además de esto hay también restricciones
para visitar a las personas que estén en
residencias de adultos mayores esto
habrá que hacerlo con cita previa y
efectivamente pues en las universidades
donde se está dando el 40 por ciento de
los focos de contagio en toda esta
región pues está el aforo máximo de 50
por ciento que será puede ser tanto en
los comedores como en los salones de
clase bueno natale aparte de eso que
otras restricciones se mantienen
bueno por una parte la de los
restaurantes digamos estos no van a
estos no van a cerrar pero van a tener
que acogerse a un nuevo protocolo
sanitario que será mucho más estricto y
que se espera pues se den los detalles
en lo corriente de este día lunes además
de esto los estadios pues que podrán
seguir acogiendo el público hasta 1000
personas máximo esto quiere decir que el
torneo de roland garros no se verá
afectado por esto ni tampoco los
partidos de fútbol ni el rugby que están
programados en los próximos 15 días
estas son digamos ya restricciones que
están funcionando así como por ejemplo
los sitios culturales los cines los
teatros todos estos siguen abiertos
porque tienen que cumplir con un
protocolo sanitario bastante estricto
que ya está en curso y bueno pues todo
esto será revisado dentro de 15 días
esperando que los indicadores pues
mejoren estos indicadores que se
utilizan para saber cómo está avanzando
la epidemia en el país gracias a usted y
en más información de kobe 19 en europa
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula van der leyen está en cuarentena
la diplomática informó que estuvo en
contacto con una persona positiva para
el virus
an der leyen explicó en su cuenta de
'twitter' que el martes pasado estuvo en
una reunión en cascais con miembros del
consejo del estado luso y uno de ellos
fue diagnosticado el domingo en el
encuentro estaba en el presidente
portugués y el primer ministro antonio
costa quienes también están siendo
analizados
y el mundo sobrepasó ya los 35 millones
de casos del nuevo coronavirus los
fallecidos son más de un millón 37 mil
en eeuu el alcalde de la ciudad de nueva
york bill de blasio propuso este domingo
a las autoridades estatales el cierre de
todas las actividades no esenciales esto
incluiría los centros educativos en 9
distritos postales donde se han
detectado brotes de kobe 19 de blasio
pidió que el bloqueo comience el 7 de
octubre pese a que nueva york es uno de
los 18 estados donde no han aumentado
los casos en las últimas dos semanas
creemos que debemos cerrar las
actividades de mayor riesgo
eso significa cenas bajo techo gimnasios
y piscinas estas actividades deben
restringirse a partir del miércoles en
la mañana usted muden para poder pero
otras actividades pueden continuar como
actividades comerciales de menor riesgo
y en una medida que ha suscitado
críticas de los expertos médicos el
presidente de eeuu incumplió su
cuarentena este domingo cuando se
trasladó en su caravana oficial para
saludar a seguidores que se habían
reunido fuera de los
donde está siendo tratado en maryland
donald trump de 74 años fue
diagnosticado con kobe 19 hace pocos
días y algunos médicos creen que este
mismo lunes se podría estar de regreso
en la casa blanca
el camino de donald trump hacia la
recuperación del cob y 19 ha sido tan
divisorio como su política renunciando a
la cuarentena a la que se supone que
está sometido mientras aún es contagioso
el domingo el presidente portando
mascarilla se sube a un automóvil para
saludar a sus seguidores algo que ha
suscitado la preocupación de los
expertos médicos que se preocupan por la
seguridad de las demás personas dentro
del vehículo minutos antes de su
improvisada salida publicó un vídeo en
su página de twitter con los nuevos
avances de la enfermedad
así que ha sido un viaje muy interesante
he aprendido mucho sobre el cob y lo
aprendí yendo realmente a la escuela
esta es la verdadera escuela esta no es
la escuela de leamos un libro y lo
entiendo lo entiendo y es una cosa muy
interesante y voy a dejar que lo sepas
una visita que ha sido considerada de
responsabilidad asombrosa según un
médico del walter reed cada persona en
el vehículo durante ese paseo
presidencial completamente innecesario
ahora tiene que estar en cuarentena
durante 14 días pueden enfermarse pueden
morir por el teatro político mandados
por trump a poner en riesgo sus vidas
por el teatro eso es una locura según
los médicos del presidente de eeuu está
actualmente en un tratamiento de cinco
días con el antiviral recibir y un
cóctel de vitaminas sus niveles
fluctuantes de oxígeno también han sido
tratados con un esteroide de tecsa meta
zona algo que la oms es sólo recomienda
en casos graves de la enfermedad
a medida que trump se recupera las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre están cada
vez más cerca con el presidente fuera de
la campaña indefinidamente sus aliados
de alto perfil están listos para asumir
el control de la campaña en persona los
próximos días incluyendo al
vicepresidente max payne y los hijos de
trump eric y tonal juniors en américa
latina' este sábado y domingo hubo
debates presidenciales en bolivia aunque
en la jornada de anoche sin la presencia
de dos de los principales candidatos
luis arce del movimiento al socialismo
más el partido de evo morales y sin el
ex líder el cívico luís fernando camacho
de creemos el evento se desarrolló en un
centro de convenciones en la paz días
atrás
arze declinó su participación del
domingo para asistir en cambio a una
entrevista de televisión en el mismo
horario junto al candidato a la
vicepresidencia de su partido el ex
canciller boliviano david choquehuanca
arce camacho y los demás candidatos sí
estuvieron en el debate del sábado en
santa cruz que trató exclusivamente
cuestiones económicas
en las noticias 14 de las 23 provincias
en argentina están en llamas con más de
200.000 hectáreas arrasadas por el fuego
que según agencias gubernamentales es en
un 95% de los casos intencional en
paraguay la situación también es crítica
las altas temperaturas allí la sequía
persistente y las quemas de basura están
detrás de este fenómeno que afecta a
gran parte del conosur marina colorado
tiene los detalles
argentina está en llamas desde hace
semanas y según datos oficiales la mano
del ser humano es responsable del 95 por
ciento de los incendios registrados ya
sea por intereses en inversiones
inmobiliarias o mineras o por las quemas
por parte de ganaderos para renovar el
pasto y ampliar sus terrenos de las 14
provincias afectadas 12 siguen teniendo
focos activos siendo córdoba y jujuy las
más críticas en el delta del paraná
ecosistema de humedales clave por su
biodiversidad
los incendios llevan activos desde junio
y el ministerio de medioambiente
argentino presentó una querella para
averiguar quiénes son responsables de
este ecocidio sin embargo organizaciones
ambientales denuncian que el gobierno no
está haciendo lo suficiente para
combatir las llamas la medida para
controlar el fuego en las provincias
afectadas son insuficientes exigimos que
se amplíen significativamente los fondos
y la infraestructura destinados a la
prevención y lucha contra los incendios
la vecina paraguay está en las mismas la
región occidental
es la más afectada con el 75% de los
focos la fuerte sequía que azota al país
sumada a las altas temperaturas
registradas a pesar de que acaba de
comenzar la primavera están avivando las
llamas que muchas veces inician con la
quema de pastizales
que quiera controlar imposible
incontrolable el primero de octubre el
gobierno paraguayo declaró la emergencia
nacional lo que desbloquea fondos y
permite pedir ayuda internacional para
combatir los incendios
avanza el noveno día de violentos
enfrentamientos entre armenia y
azerbaiyán en torno a la región
separatista de nagorno karabaj a las
autoridades de stepánek en la capital
del territorio reportaron ataques con
artillería pesada por parte de
azerbaiyán el domingo engancha la
segunda ciudad más importante de
azerbaiyán un equipo de france 24
reportó las secuelas de un bombardeo
una violenta tarde en este pana kertész
la capital de la región de nagorno
karabaj a tanto las autoridades de la
zona como el gobierno armenio denuncian
que los bombardeos fueron dirigidos por
azerbaiyán hacia esta ciudad que
amaneció en medio de la zozobra
azerbayán también acusa a armenia de
atacar objetivos civiles engancha la
segunda ciudad en importancia en el
oeste de su país
allí abul lleva de 72 años la despertó a
una explosión
un misil que cayó cerca y destruyó las
ventanas de su casa y aterrorizó a su
familia
los niños estaban durmiendo justo ahí
pero no se lastimaron yo sólo vine y los
saque y ellos se escaparon
la devastación se ve en las calles de
ganja a 100 kilómetros del límite con
nagorno karabaj a las autoridades
azerbaiyanas dicen que cuatro misiles
cayeron en barrios residenciales de esta
ciudad que mataron a una persona e
hirieron seriamente a otras
para algunos nuestra presencia a causa
de hostilidad y un sentido de injusticia
figura ellos son de francia son de
francia yo no trabajo para el gobierno
francés
bueno dígales muéstreles ellos
simplemente eran civiles estamos lejos
de nagorno karabaj este parlamentario
local está dispuesto a difundir el
mensaje oficial
estos misiles vinieron directamente
desde armenia quieren que respondamos y
ataquemos territorio armenio
las autoridades de azerbaiyán alegan que
esta provocación desde armenia busca
prolongar el conflicto
armenia niega rol alguno en los
bombardeos y dice que estos fueron
dirigidos por las fuerzas de nagorno
karabaj a quienes dicen que buscaban
atacar instalaciones militares
y en irak el ejército dijo en un
comunicado que dos cohetes impactaron
este domingo por la noche en el área de
bagdad pero sin causar víctimas uno de
los cohetes cayó cerca del hotel babylon
que es utilizado por viajeros iraquíes y
a veces para reuniones gubernamentales
el ejército iraquí culpó a grupos
terroristas por el ataque y dijo que los
cohetes fueron disparados desde un área
en la parte occidental de la capital
y revisemos a esta hora nuestro sitio
web air france 24 punto coma al aire
ustedes se van a encontrar la noticia de
donald trump quien salió brevemente del
hospital para saludar a sus seguidores
también parís que entra en máxima alerta
por la propagación de los contagios de
kobe 19 y lea con nosotros la historia
de la caravana de emigrantes que
confrontó a guatemala y honduras así
como los avances en los enfrentamientos
que se desarrollan actualmente en
nagorno karabaj el enclave separatista
habitado principalmente por armenios
pero en azerbaiyán hasta aquí está
informativo siga con nosotros en france
24 ya regresamos con más
[Música]